- LearnStormers, my
name is Josh Sundquist.
I am a YouTuber, best-selling author,
and a paralympic ski racer.
I first started ski racing
when I was a teenager.
I went to my first race
thinking I was the best skier
of all time, and it was
gonna be amazing, right?
I was super excited about
it, and I'm sure that's kinda
how you feel when you start
anything in life, right?
Maybe even when you started this class.
I went through the course,
and I actually fell
on the third turn in the course.
That was really disappointing.
I expected I was gonna ski
really well, and I fell.
I think that is an
inevitable part of anything,
including this course, right?
You're really excited at first,
and then something happens,
a problem, you fall, you get
discouraged, and it's in that
moment I think you have choice
about do you want to quit.
Do you just want to be
like, "eh, it's not for me
because I fell" or do
you want to say, "no,
falling is just part of the process."
It's just something that
happens along the way.
If you wanna cross the finish
line at the end race course,
as if you wanna finish the
class, you have to get back up.
I got back up, and I fell down again,
and got back up and fell down.
I actually fell down five
times in this race course.
It was not very good, as it turns out.
But I kept getting back
up, and for that reason,
I eventually crossed the finish line.
What I want to say to you
is that when you fall,
when something doesn't work
out quite the way that you
wanted, when you get discouraged,
and that's not a reason to quit,
that's just part of the process.
It's in those moments that
you have to look at the finish
line that you're trying to reach and say,
"all right, I'm gonna get back up
and I'm gonna keep getting
back up as many times
as it takes until I
cross that finish line."
So, keep up the good work,
keep getting back up,
and good luck in the rest of your class.